multiply 3x plus 2 times 5x minus 7. so
we're multiplying two binomials i'm
actually going to show you two really
equivalent ways of doing this one that
you might hear in a classroom and it's
kind of a more of a mechanical
memorizing way of doing it which might
be faster but you really don't know what
you're doing and then there's the one
where you're essentially just applying
something that you already know in kind
of a logical way so i'll first do the
memorizing way that you might be exposed
to and they'll
they'll use something called foil
foil foils let me write this down here
foil so you could immediately see that
whenever someone gives you a mnemonic to
memorize that you're doing something
pretty mechanical so foil literally
stands for
first
first outside let me write it this way
let me write foil
foil
where f the f in foil stands for first
the o in foil stands for outside
the i stands for inside
and then the l stands for last and the
reason why i don't like these things is
when you're 35 years old you're not
going to remember what foil stood for
and then you're not going to remember
how to multiply this binomial but let's
just apply foil so first says just
multiply the first terms in each of
these binomials so just multiply the 3x
times the 5x so 3x
times the 5x the outside part tells us
multiply the outside term so in this
case you have 3x on the outside and you
have negative
7 on the outside so that is plus 3x
times negative 7 the inside
the inside well the inside terms here
are 2
and 5x so plus 2 times 5x and then
finally you have the last terms
you have the 2 and the negative 7. so
the last term is two times negative
seven two
times negative seven so what you're
essentially doing is just making sure
that you're multiplying each term by
every other term here where what we're
essentially doing is multiplying the
doing the distributive property twice
we're multiplying the 3x times 5x minus
7. so 3x times 5x minus 7 is 3x times 5x
plus 3x minus 7 and we're multiplying
the 2 times 5x minus 7 to give us these
terms but anyway let's just multiply
this out just to get our answer 3x times
5x the same thing as 3 times 5 times x
times x which is the same thing as 15
x squared you could use x to the first
times x to the first you multiply the
x's you get x squared 3 times 5 is 15.
this term right here 3 times negative 7
is negative 21 and then you have your x
right over here and then you have this
term which is 2 times 5 which is 10
times x so plus
10x and then finally you have this term
here in blue 2 times negative 7 is
negative 14. and we aren't done yet we
can simplify this a little bit we have 2
like terms here we have this let me find
a new color we have two
terms with a x to the first power or
just an x term right over here so if we
have negative 21 of something and you
add 10 or another way if you have 10 of
something and you subtract 21 of them
you're going to have negative 11 of that
something and we put the other terms
here you have 15
15 x squared and then you have your
minus 14
and we are done now i said i would show
you another way to do it so i want to
show you why the distributive property
can get us here without having to
memorize foil so the distributive
property tells us that if we're look if
we're multiplying something times an
expression you just have to multiply it
times every term in the expression so we
can distribute we can distribute the 5x
onto the three or actually we could let
me view it this way
we could distribute the 5x minus 7 this
whole thing onto the 3x plus 2. let's
let me just change the order since we're
used to distributing something from the
left so this is the same thing as 5x
minus 7 times 3x plus 2. i just swapped
the two expressions and we can
distribute this whole thing times each
of these terms now what happens if i
take 5x minus 7 times 3x well that's
just going to be
3x times 5x minus 7. so i've just just
distributed the 5x minus 7 times 3x and
to that i'm going to add 2 times
5x minus 7. i've just distributed the 5x
minus 7 onto the 2.
now if you now we can do the
distributive property again we can
distribute the 3x onto the 5x we can
distribute the 3x onto the 5x and we can
distribute the 3x onto the negative 7.
we can distribute the 2 onto the 5x over
here
and we can distribute the 2 on that
negative 7
on that negative 7. now if we do it like
this what do we get
3x times 5x that's this right over here
if we do 3x times negative 7 that's this
term right over here
if you do 2 times 5x that's this term
right over here if you do 2 times
negative 7
that is this term right over here so we
got the exact same result that we got
with foil now foil can be faster if you
just want to do it you kind of can skip
to this step i i i think it's important
that you know that this is how it
actually works just in case you do
forget this when you're 35 or 45 years
old and you're faced with multiplying
binomial you just have to remember the
distributive property